je parlais des difficultés de la scala
en voilà d'autres celle du muséum
d'histoire naturelle de paris
ce musée mais on connaît généralement le
jardin des plantes un jardin où vont
jouer les enfants et où ils vont surtout
voir les animaux mais depuis trois mois
la ménagerie du jardin des plantes est
fermée au public
on enquête après la mort suspecte de
plusieurs animaux il fallait sans doute
fermer la ménagerie mais les recherches
ne vont pas vite et en attendant le
muséum père les 30000 francs les 3
millions anciens que lui rapporter
chaque semaine les entrées des enfants
or le muséum c'est aussi des
laboratoires de recherche sur les
sciences naturelles et ses laboratoires
sans argent vivent mal les chercheurs
s'inquiètent et annonce que si on ne les
aide pas le musée la mort a vécu le
symbole de ce musée malades et pourtant
plein de richesses uniques au monde
c'est peut-être à la grande galerie de
zoologie une galerie fermé au public
depuis plus de dix ans et dans les
collections inestimables pourrissent
tombe en poussière
tout est prêt pour temps pour sauver
cette galerie pour sauver ce qui peut
encore l'être
les plans d'une nouvelle galerie sont
terminées il ne manque que les crédits
nécessaires pour que revive ce qui
devient plus qu'un musée un mausolée
qu'est ce qui est arrivé ouvrir le parc
c'est très simple à dire depuis 50 ans
le muséum manque de crédit souffre d'un
désintérêt des pouvoirs publics ce qui
fait que ces bâtiments n'ont pas pu être
entretenue pour donner quelques maigres
crédit à nos chercheurs
nous avons été obligés d'abandonner tout
ce qui est à proprement parler
muséologie pédagogie dans cet
établissement il faut pas oublier que
nous avons ici toute la grande faune
d'afrique d'asie
nous allons ici toute une série
d'espèces qui n'ont jamais été filmées
qui n'ont jamais été photographiée
simplement parce que les conditions sont
trop difficiles ou à l'heure actuelle
pour des raisons diverses les pays sont
fermées à des cinéastes soient les
photographes et parmi ces pièces
certaines sont perdus et bien certaines
sont perdus je pense également à ce
qu'on appelle dit quentin savin découvre
une nouvelle espèce
eh bien il choisit un spécimen qui a
véritablement le type de l'espèce qui
est comparable simuler météo mètre
étalon
ensuite le les scientifiques viennent
comparer leurs propres spécimens à cette
espèce des talons vous passez que ceci
constitue un matériel particulièrement
précieux heures nous en avons des
centaines de milliers
et ce matériel à l'heure actuelle et
pour une bonne partie compromis en dépit
de tous les efforts que nous avons pu
faire il ya une bonne partie notre
matériel qui ne pourra pas être sauvées
quoi que nous fassions
nous sommes sollicités sans cesse par
des groupes scolaires qui veulent sous
la direction de leur maître ou des
nôtres venir en souvenir recevoir un
enseignement mais sur l'ovi sûr lotta
devant la pièce et c'est ça qui compte à
l'europe
vous auriez montrer cette salle
installant étrangers bien les savants
étrangers viennent ici bien sûr viens
ici car il ya encore à l'heure actuelle
un certain nombre de spécimens du
matériel particulièrement précieux qui
est utile à leur recherche
et qu'en est-il eh bien ils sont bien
entendu effaré effondré le voir dans
quel état se trouve tout cela
que vont devenir les animaux naturalisés
actuellement c'est assez exceptionnel de
faire des montages d'animaux ce moment
parce que la galerie et en tombant en
ruines en n'y a plus de place pour eux
il ya combien de temps vous êtes ici il
ya 27 ans 27 ans vous fabriquez 27 ans
et je n'ai pas le sentiment quelquefois
travailler pour rien quand vous voyez
cette galerie qui tombe en ville est à
vous savez ici on se pose guère la
question on a quelquefois des montages
affaires en effet une fois après ça je
ne vous demandez pas où ils vont bien au
début quand on les voyait partir à la
galerie ça me faisait un peu mal au
coeur parce que la galerie on la voyait
se dégrader petit à petit et maintenant
au poinçonnet alors leur romance pose
plus du tout la question le fait qu'on
puisse plus justement et naturalisé les
animaux faire des montages comme celui
ci vous pensez que c'est grave sur un
plan signifie c'est très grave rit parce
que et à cri des remises de perdre la
main et dans quelques temps si on a des
montages à faire on sera obligé de le
faire faire à l'étranger
quand je suis arrivé au muséum en 48 49
je me suis occupé du musée de kimberley
en est peut-être deux ans après je me
suis aperçu que il y avait des fuites à
l'intérieur je l'aï donc signalé
on a fait venir les experts pour faire
un devis et le devis se monte à environ
4 millions ancien trouvé que c'était
trop cher on a attendu deux ans on pour
faire des économies a fait leur avenir
les experts mais mes frites s'était
aggravé et les experts nous en donner un
avis de 12 ou 13 millions en deux ans
teint
tant et si bien qu'on a tous laissés à
l'abandon
quelqu'un a posé un pigeon mort sur la
tête couverte de poussière du duc
d'orléans
aujourd'hui il faut 50 millions 5
milliards anciens pour sauver la grande
galerie du muséum
il faut creuser des silos qui abriteront
les animaux le temps des travaux des
ménages et les bocaux qui outre des
centaines de milliers d'animaux
contiennent 600 mille litres d'alcool
c'est un travail de géant mais les
chercheurs du muséum jure qu'il est
possible à réaliser si on ne perd pas
trop de temps
parce que c'est une cause perdue ou
est-ce que c'est récupérable
et bien non ce n'est certainement pas
une cause perdue mais je dirais que peut
être c'est la dernière chance que nous
allons rencontrer maintenant de sauver
ce matériel il y à ici dans ce musée du
louvre de la nature un million cent
cinquante mille espèces c'est à dire
plusieurs millions d'animaux des hommes
ils ont chassés et tués pour la science
et les savants leur avait redonné une
seconde vie pour qu'il soit aux yeux de
tous les témoins unique de race 10 parmi
les centaines de milliers d'entre eux
sont venus mourir là à nouveau
définitivement et continuent à mourir
chaque jour cachée de tous les pieds
dans la poussière la tête sous la pluie
qui tombe des gouttières un savon
étrangers à visiter la galerie il ya
quelques temps seul en rapportant les
clés aux professeurs dorst ce savant
avait les larmes aux yeux